[Music]
exceptional leaders the ones who come to
mind when you think about people you
admire is that they are known for
continuing their development throughout
their lives folks who take a growth
mindset see the challenges they're
facing as something that they could
develop enough to achieve or overcome or
master or learn from so that a failure
from a growth mindset perspective is an
opportunity to learn the typical
approach is to be judgmental to think of
what's happening as somehow inevitable
and then to worry about assigning blame
for all those things that are going
wrong if we can develop more of a growth
mindset we can do a much better job of
creating in ourselves a set of
capabilities that can make us more
successful precisely because we've run
into difficulties in the past so at all
levels exceptional leadership for you as
an individual for the organization of
the people you touch their and for the
world all have to do with whether or not
you take a developmental approach or a
judgmental approach how do your actions
as a leader affect the growth mindset of
others what can you do to make it so
that your workplace is more
developmental and less judgement
transform your approach to leadership
excellence and development learn more
about si P the Stanford executive
program
you
[Music]